und Layla erregt die Gemüter manche
Stadt obere sind besorgt ein Lied so ein
Lied auf unseren Volksfesten das geht
nicht mein sie wir müssen da mal
reinhören
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
sie schöner Jünger geiler
dieser Song steht seit vier Wochen an
der Spitze der deutschen Charts der
Sommerhit von DJ Robin und Schürze sorgt
am Ballermann für mega Stimmung in
Würzburg dagegen für mega Verstimmung
denn auf einem dortigen Volksfest soll
der Hit gar nicht erst gespielt werden
der Streit um das Lied über eine
Puffmutter beschäftigt mittlerweile
sogar schon die Politik
[Applaus]
na das mit dem untersagen hat hier wohl
nicht so ganz geklappt im Festzelt
schert sich niemand um die Forderungen
der Stadt Würzburg die Verantwortlichen
sich an den Veranstalter gewendet diesen
gebeten darauf zu verzichten den
Ballermann Hit Layla auf ihrem Volksfest
zu spielen das geht Layla ist ja jetzt
in aller Munde weil wir den Text einmal
analysiert haben und in der
Textgestaltung in dem Aufbau fällt dann
schon auf dass die Puffmutter und die
dann reduziert wird auch als Frau und
als Wesen
diskriminierend besungen wird und wir
haben vor einem Jahr eine Vereinbarung
hier in Würzburg getroffen mit unserem
festzeltbetreiber das rassistische
extreme oder feministische Lieder
sexistische Lieder nicht mehr aufgeführt
werden doch so wie die Gemeinde es sieht
sehen es längst nicht alle in der Stadt
auf dem Volksfest in Würzburg herrscht
ein absolutes Unverständnis für diese
Entscheidung hier feiert jeder den Song
im Bierzelt macht natürlich schon
Stimmung wenn es jeder singt und fühlst
du die als Frau belästigt von dem Lied
oder von dem Text vor allem nein
eigentlich nicht also ich höre das jetzt
nicht so oft aber also ich finde es
eigentlich auch ganz gut so wenn es halt
alle mitsingen oder so also ich finde es
gibt schon länger solche Lieder und
finde es ein bisschen übertrieben also
ich mag das Lied und ich feiere es ja
auch an so einem Fest ist das ganz okay
also sie fühlen sich nicht belästigt nee
überhaupt nicht darf ich fragen ist
behindert aussieht fühlt sich belästigt
von Layla auf keinen Fall die Geschichte
um das Lied haben sie nicht mitbekommen
doch jetzt schon nach dem zuständig in
der Zeitung steht und was sagen sie dazu
Quatsch und auch über unsere
Landesgrenzen hinaus läuft leider in
Dauerschleife unser Bild Brummi Brian
schickt uns dieses Video aus seinem
Familienurlaub in der Türkei
[Musik]
aber auch auf dem Ballermann läuft die
Puffmutter Leila rauf und runter auch
hier versteht keiner die Aufregung
leider ist unser Lieblingslied hier so
sieht's nämlich aus auf jeden Fall ab
und darauf würde ich sagen wir stimmen
alle noch mal ein ich habe
ein Pop online gekauft
Jünger geiler
la la la la la allerdings ist die
Debatte um Layla längst keine kleine
mehr unzählige Medien berichten fragen
wie sexistisch dieser Song sei von
künstlerischer Freiheit keine Spur die
Diskussion nimmt so ein großes Ausmaß an
dass sich sogar Bundesjustizminister
Marco Buschmann zu Wort meldet über
Twitter schreibt er man muss
Schlagertexte nicht mögen man kann sie
sogar doof oder geschmacklos finden Sie
aber behördlich zu verbieten finde ich
ist eins zu viel der Fairness halber
behördlich wurde hier gar nichts
verboten es wurde gebeten es nicht zu
spielen aber selbst das findet
fdp-bundestagsabgeordneter Max Mordhorst
überzogen ja finde ich schade also ich
habe schon manchmal das Gefühl da wird
mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wenn einige
Behörden Englisch verstehen würden würde
glaube ich jedes zweite Lied verboten
die Leute hören es gerne lasst es jedoch
hören übrigens Songs wie Layla gab es
schon in den 80ern erinnern noch hier
ran
[Musik]
Skandal im Sperrbezirk von der Spider
Murphy Gang ein Partyhit nichts weiter
und selbst wenn der aktuelle Ballermann
Hit nicht nur auf Platz eins der
deutschen Charts ist sondern auch das
Gesprächsthema vom Streit um den Song
zeigen sich die Besucher des Volksfestes
in Würzburg am Ende nur wenig
beeindruckt
[Applaus]
Layla erhitzt die Gemüter und genau
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit ikke
Hüftgold Ecke kannst du den Streit um
den Songtexten nachvollziehen
genau Udo Jürgens 17 Jahre blondes Haar
war das rechtlich und moralisch
einwandfrei kann man sich die Frage
stellen Falco hat über Genie gesungen
Skandal Bezirk waren Hit wurde damals
auch von vom Bayerischen Rundfunk
verboten und was bewirkt die Zensur ein
Verbot oder eine Unterlassung oder eine
Untersagung irgendwie Leute lassen sich
nichts verbieten es geht um
Meinungsfreiheit es geht um kürzere
Freiheit und es geht um die Party nach
Corona darum geht's nämlich auch in den
Köpfen und ich glaube es ist alles sehr
sehr heiß gekocht gerade
wenn wir noch ein anderes Songs denken
zum Beispiel ich habe eine Zwiebel auf
dem Kopf ich bin ein Döner denn döner
macht schöner ist genauso ein Beispiel
oder
ja wir haben auch zehn nackte Friseusen
mit unwahrscheinlich schönen Haaren und
so zieht sich das durch den Ballermann
wie ein roter Faden und das gehört zur
Kultur zur feier-kultur seit 40 Jahren
feiern wir diese Musik und es gibt
tausende dieser Beispiele und ich glaube
die Herren und Damen der die Stadt Väter
und Mütter von Würzburg sollten sich mal
bisschen zurück erinnern an ihre Jugend
ich glaube dass der ein oder andere Song
dabei war auf den sie auch abgegangen
sind der nicht so astrein war
wir gehen denn deine Künstler damit um
DJ und und Schürze sind natürlich von
dem Erfolg komplett überwältigt und sind
natürlich auch ein Stück weit schockiert
über die Diskussion die entbrannt ist
dass wir haben die Jungs das Lied die
Jungs bei einem inhalieren Laune
geschrieben und es ist es trifft einfach
die Faust aufs Auge
und genau anscheinend den Zeitgeist bei
unserem Ballermann und die zwei sollen
auch weiterhin Erfolg genießen
die Menschen lieben diesen Hit aber
welche Reaktionen bekommst du denn aus
deinem musikalischen Umfeld auf diese
Kritik
naja jeder weiß bei uns wer mit Musik
und Medien zu tun hat dass das was
gerade passiert das Beste ist was dem
Song passieren kann wir haben aktuell
Abrufzahlen auf Spotify ich kann ja als
Plattenfirma live reinschauen
unfassbar hohe also die höchsten
Abrufzahlen ever das heißt die Nummer
wird am Freitag wieder auf eins sein die
wird im besten Falle die nächsten Wochen
nicht mehr von der Heinz verschwinden
weil die Leute auch genau aus dem Grund
und aus Trotz äh diesen Song hören und
verbreiten werden es gibt jetzt eine
Petition im Netz freeleiler es werden
unfassbar viele memes gerade erstellt
auf tiktok ist dass das Hauptthema
gerade das heißt ich sage Danke an die
stadtfeder und Mütter in Würzburg und
auch in Düsseldorf die befeuern das ja
gerade auch aber auch die Cranger Kirmes
versucht gerade ein booking Rück
abzuwickeln mit uns mit DJ Robin weil
die Stadt Herne ein Verbot ausspricht
und da gehen wir jetzt schon in
rechtliche Fragen rein darf man das so
ich glaube die de sollten wir jetzt auch
zu Ende führen
unbedingt vielen Dank für das Gespräch
ikke Hüftgold